[Music]
all right so i am the
aforementioned hunter who is very lucky
to work with kelly baldwin at cal poly
university down in san luis obispo i
teach a lot of statistical computing and
compu
data science type courses in lots of
different languages and stuff
and i feel like what's pretty much
agreed on at this point
even though a lot of the education
surrounding data science is still in
flux is
there's math there's statistics there's
computer science
and then there's some kind of domain
application knowledge right that third
usually element of the venn diagram that
you've probably all seen or heard of or
something like that
but it's that third piece the domain
knowledge or application that
can vary so much in everybody's kind of
implementation of data science education
but i would argue that these things
should remain constant
right so if we can all agree on the math
the statistics the computer science and
those kinds of skills
with whatever language you may happen to
you know see it in
that and and no matter what domain
application
you kind of see or or experience right
or deliver to your students
these things need to be in all of it
right
you may have courses and data structures
you may have courses in regression
models or machine learning
and stuff like that right but at least
at cal poly we don't have a course
in version control right or a course in
reproducibility but these are things
that are inherent and important for
all of these topics in all these courses
right students need to see these
things these need to be harped on and
emphasized i think
in any data science education so um
besides positing that
these are kind of foundational r and r
studio are really special tools for
uh implementing and involving these
these topics i think
right so to start off reproducibility
this is like the deadest horse i feel
like of this conference like you guys
have heard about reproducibility and
lots and lots of talks already so
there's actually not too much for me to
say here
except what you already know in one
sense right so the idea
if you can't read the text shy is saying
what am i supposed to be looking for
if you're being pass code by somebody
else or if i have students passing code
around
or or things like that then that code
should be kind of robust
enough and built in such a good way that
it can be kind of run as is right that
analyses workflows pipelines are
reproducible right
so you shouldn't have to really look for
anything and if you are going to look
for anything you want to tweak anything
it should be
kind of parameterized well built in a
robust way but
again you guys have already heard this a
lot of times if you weren't at
jj's keynote go check that out for how
our studio is
epic at reproducibility or karl how's
talk from yesterday on education where
he also talked about
how awesome our studio is for
reproducibility
[Music]
communication should not be magic right
it shouldn't be
just a black box for how all the data
science gets done right we're all
delivering to somebody it might be a
teammate it might be a supervisor it
might be
people in all different kinds of
positions or on different teams and
things like that
and the how of what we did and the why
and all that kind of stuff shouldn't be
uh shouldn't be magic um but
this jiff's awesome so uh i had to
include that um
and so communication has to be a huge
part of whatever
coursework your our students are going
through right and our markdown and shiny
are
phenomenal at that you guys have seen
tons and tons of talks i'm learning new
things all the time about
different ways that these can be used to
that end
so gordon shotwell's talk was really
nice yesterday on technical debt but
everything you've seen so far on our
markdown here
is good for communication version
control
right there's all these different
versions of possibly the same thing
right code analysis and stuff like that
going on
and you've got to track it right along
with reproducibility
we need resiliency in the data science
pipeline and so
the git integration in r studio again is
totally epic right so if you're not
familiar with this
you probably all use version control of
some sort and you may use it outside of
rstudio but you can use it from within
our studio so i would definitely
recommend checking that out
and getting your students hooked up to
that
practical application uh you've probably
heard this implemented a lot of people's
different
universities or programs programs
programs programs
um there's a practicum right or some
client based project or something like
that this is also critical we can equip
students all we want in the classroom
but
right this football helmet's not really
useful in the classroom right you can
give them all the tools and stuff but
you've got to get them practice with it
like
real practice with it and so learn by
doing client based projects are huge
our projects are obviously a really nice
tool for that um
our packages and having students maybe
build packages and stuff like that are
all really good ways to kind of get them
into that mode of what they might be
doing later
with uh you know on the job and finally
data ethics this often maybe gets swept
to the side or isn't explicitly
addressed but everything and everybody
involved
in the data need to be cool with it
right need to be on the right side of it
this has also been talked and touched on
in a lot of different ways here at
the conference and so i won't say too
much except that everybody needs to be
treated and considered well so that is
it
uh please reach out i'm happy to discuss
education with anybody and everybody so
[Music]